[Music]
should unemployment insurance or UI for
short cover paid family leave president
Trump's budget includes a proposal to do
just that
new parents would get you I checked for
up to six weeks after the birth or
adoption of a child that sounds good but
it also would require higher taxes on
jobs and add administrative complexity
to an already strained program in 2018 a
third of UI recipients exhausted
benefits without finding a new job and
almost one in eight benefit dollars were
paid in error that's hundreds of
thousands of unemployed people
exhausting benefits and over three
billion dollars in miss spending the
administrators running the unemployment
insurance program need to focus on
reconnecting UI recipients to work and
making sure payments are going to those
who really need them there are lots of
ideas for how to help families with paid
leave but adding a paid leave program
for employed people to the unemployment
insurance program designed to help
unemployed people doesn't make much
sense do you think the unemployment
insurance programs should cover paid
family leave let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI